some alarming breaking news to bring you  from new york this is the scene right  now it's around quarter to 10 in the  morning there the fire department of new  york are saying a number of people have  been shot at a subway station in  brooklyn firefighters responded to  reports of smoke at the 36th street  station in the sunset park neighborhood  there they found multiple gunshot  victims and unexploded devices  new york city police say they are  responding to reports of people wounded  either by gunfire or explosion  that's all we have at the moment we'll  bring you more as we get it but that's  the developing story in brooklyn new  york this afternoon